hi i'm mike davis and i'm auditioning  for the scheduled release video  hey this is tom brady  that's great this is sean payton let me  in jameis  grab the swiss army knife not that this  is jameis  apparently he meant tayson all right  this is dan campbell  i'm not here for your southern cooking i  mean kneecaps or nothing  i hope that was a good one all right  this is bill belichick  how did tom win the super bowl i  actually didn't really follow football  last year  i'm not crying i'm not crying  how do you feel about that i actually  like the second one  all right this is surpr wow freddy you  look perfect  dude bella chick it's surpr  it's his name all right this is josh  allen man i want to jump on that table  no no  [Music]  i'm auditioning for the role of mike  davis turn on the sprinkler  i hope i did good um i'm i'm trying over  here for my first time did you like  bill belichick was fine